vamos a tomarnos una transformación
regresamos al punto de las
transformaciones que van en general de
un rn a un r m
ok va del espacio r n de n dimensiones
al espacio r m muy bien y vamos a bueno
sabemos que toda transformación que va
de rn a rm se puede expresar digamos si
aplicamos t a un vector x que se
encuentra en rn esto lo podemos expresar
como la multiplicación de una matriz a
por el vector x y esta matriz por
supuesto tiene que tener dimensiones m
por m y esto es porque se toma vectores
en rn así que el número de columnas que
debe tener es n y cada una de esas
columnas debe de ser vectores nrm verdad
entonces debe tener m m filas eso es lo
que estamos diciendo así que podemos
volver a lo que hemos estado hablando en
los últimos vídeos hemos estado hablando
de invertibilidad de funciones y podemos
fácilmente aplicarlo
transformación y realmente podemos
hacerlo pues porque cuando hablábamos de
de transformaciones o de funciones y de
si eran invertibles o no en los últimos
en el último par de vídeos en realidad
hablábamos de que iban funciones de
cualquier conjunto x a cualquier
conjunto y en particular podríamos
pensar que esos conjuntos xy son este rn
y este ere m así que vamos a pensar un
poquito en ello digamos que ahora aquí
nuestros dibujitos pues en realidad este
conjunto va a ser r n ok y también tengo
mi conjunto crm
este va a ser rm esta transformación es
es una función
específicamente que mapea cada punto x
de rn lo mapea o lo manda algún punto
acá nrm que de hecho ese punto está dado
perdón a por la matriz la matriz a
perdón por el vector xy esto es nuestra
transformación t muy bien entonces la
pregunta inmediata que que se nos puede
ocurrir después de haber visto los
vídeos anteriores es ver si esta
transformación es invertible será cierto
que más que será cierto bajo qué
condiciones nuestra transformación t es
invertible ok y vimos de hecho en en el
vídeo anterior que para que una función
sea invertible debe cumplir dos cosas la
primera de ellas es que ésta te debe ser
debe ser sobre
o que también el nombre rimbombante y
extravagante para decir que te sea una
función a una transformación sobre es
decirle su proyectiva verdad debe ser su
proyectiva y otra condición para que te
sea la transformación sea invertible es
que te debe ser debe ser 1 a 1 verdad 1
a 1
y también tenemos un nombre estilizado y
elegante para decir que una
transformación sea 1 a 1 y esto es que
sea inyectaba verdad entonces en este
vídeo solo me voy a centrar en esta
primera parte sólo me voy a centrar en
las condiciones para que esta función
sea su project y va ya después veremos
qué pasa o qué debe pasar para que sea
inyectaba o 1 a 1 ok entonces repasemos
qué significa que sea su proyectiva y
y que una función sea su proyectiva
quiere decir que si yo me tomo cualquier
punto en la imagen o más que en la
imagen en el contra dominio ok en rm
digamos yo tengo aquí este vector de
entonces para decir que esta función es
su proyectiva o que sobre yo debo poder
encontrar un elemento un puntito aquí en
rn que al aplicarle la transformación
vaya a caer en este ve ahora éste no
tiene que ser único podría haber otro
punto que también vaya a dar ave pero al
menos debemos garantizar que exista uno
puede haber varios puede haber 5 10 20
los que sean pero para cada punto en rm
debe existir otro que vaya a dar a este
punto ve bajo la transformación t por
supuesto entonces vamos a ver bajo qué
condiciones nuestra transformación
aplicada x que la pensamos como una
matriz a de m por n que multiplica el
vector x bajo qué condiciones esta
transformación es
sobre aunque yo su proyectiva entonces
la definición de que sea sobre sobre
implica que para cualquier punto ve cómo
como lo pusimos acá arriba para
cualquier ve cualquier ve que se
encuentre en nuestro codominio rm debe
existir al menos al menos una solución
una solución solución
a esta ecuación que ha x es igual a b
verdad eso significa la transformación
que exista al menos un punto x tal que
la transformación aplicado asx sea de
verdad y la transformación es a por x ok
donde donde x por supuesto tiene que
estar en nuestro dominio eso es r
ok entonces pensemos realmente qué
implica esta expresión ok porque la
matriz a la matriz a la podemos escribir
como si viéramos a sus columnas verdad
sus columnas puede ser el vector a1 el
vector a 2 y así sucesivamente hasta el
vector
n dijimos que tiene n columnas verdad
entonces esta matriz a la podemos ver
como la matriz cuyas columnas son a1 a2
y así sucesivamente hasta a n entonces
quién es quién es o cómo podemos
expresar a por x buenos y además x lo lo
ponemos en sus coordenadas es decir el
vector x es x 1 x 2 y así sucesivamente
hasta x en verdad x m entonces esta
multiplicación de la matriz a que tiene
estas columnas por el vector ya lo hemos
visto simplemente es la combinación
lineal x 1 a 1
+ x 2 a 2 y así sumamos hasta x n por a
m ok entonces esta multiplicación de
matriz por este vector x simplemente me
da una combinación lineal donde los
coeficientes que anteceden alude a las
digamos a los vectores columna de
nuestra matriz a son justamente las
coordenadas de nuestro vector x ok
entonces qué condiciones
necesitamos para que esto sea igual a
nuestro vector b cuando donde b puede
ser cualquier vector en rm ok entonces
para que esto sea cierto para que esto
sea cierto necesitamos que t que que el
espacio vectorial generado por los dos
vectores columna sea todo el espacio r m
es decir yo quiero expresar cualquier
elemento de rm como combinación lineal
de los de los vectores columna de mi
matriz entonces necesito que el espacio
generado por estos vectores sea
o sea perdón todo rm ok entonces vamos a
escribir eso para que nuestra
transformación te sea sobre sea sobre o
que sea su proyectiva ok
sobre qué
el espacio vectorial generado por los
vectores a 1 a 2 y así sucesivamente
hasta a n debe ser todo el espacio
rm es decir que no importa cualquier
vector en que que me tome en r m yo lo
puede expresar como combinación lineal
de estos vectores verdad donde además rm
es justo mi dominio de la transformación
verdad entonces estamos pensando que
podríamos asignarle ciertos pesos que
serían como estos coeficientes a los
vectores de a1 a2 y hasta n para que
podamos expresar cualquier vector en rm
como como esta combinación lineal
correcto entonces en realidad estamos
pensando que el espacio vectorial
generado por todos estos vectores tiene
un nombre verdad y de hecho ese espacio
vectorial es el que se le conoce como el
espacio columna de nuestra matriz ok
entonces necesitamos que el espacio
columna de nuestra
o sea justamente todo el espacio r m y
nuevamente nuestra pregunta se sigue
convirtiendo en otras preguntas cuando
esto es cierto que el espacio columna de
nuestra matriz sea rm eso sería una
solución para decir cuando la
transformación es sobre ok entonces
regresemos a la ecuación a x igual a b
digamos que tengo la ecuación a x igual
a b ok y cómo es que resolvemos siempre
este problema
este problema lo resolvemos poniendo la
matriz aumentada verdad ponemos una
matriz una matriz que tenga aquí justo a
la matriz a y aquí como columna al
vector b correcto entonces como como
resolvíamos este este problema de
determinar si tenía soluciones o no esta
ecuación entonces regresábamos o más
bien reescribimos esto en su forma
reducida y escalonada verdad
digamos que si eres la forma forma
reducida y escalonada por renglones eso
es lo que quiere decir esto de aquí de
nuestra matriz a entonces de esta forma
pasa vamos a esta otra pasamos a la
matriz oa la forma reducida y escalonada
por renglones de nuestra matriz a y del
otro lado pues tendremos algún otro
vector verdad algún otro vector que se
obtiene de seguir este procedimiento de
hacer operaciones sobre esta esta matriz
aumentada para llegar hasta esta otra
forma entonces la pregunta es cuando
esto tiene o no solución
digamos en realidad podemos tener
muchísimas o casi ninguna solución
recordemos un poquito verdad
perdón lo que quise decir fue que
podemos tener muchísimas soluciones una
o no tener soluciones recordemos que
este proceso de hacer la forma reducida
y escalonada simplemente es llevar a
llegar a ésta a esta forma es mediante
las operaciones que ya sabemos pues
expresar lo a lo mejor de alguna forma
donde tenemos renglones perdón columnas
pivote verdad donde pivote quiere decir
que tenemos un 1 y puro 0 después verdad
a lo mejor está este no es pivote este
puede ser un 2 con otros ceros qué sé yo
a lo mejor aquí si tenemos un pivote en
fin no podemos tener otro otro por aquí
es pero recuerden muy bien la idea de de
sacar las formas reducidas y escalonadas
de las formas reducidas y escalonadas
por renglones por
por renglones de una matriz es
exactamente esta idea verdad entonces
además hay que recordar que los pivotes
son esas son esas columnas esos vectores
columna donde tenemos una única entrada
que sea distinta de cero verdad y que
que esté que puede ser en particular
bueno vamos a decir que que sea una
verdad entonces esos son nuestros
pivotes y nos preguntamos entonces
cuando esto de aquí no tiene solución
entonces si queremos ver cuando tiene
solución bueno es también me equivalente
a ver cuando no tiene solución verdad
cuando cuando esto
cuando esto no tiene
solución y por qué digo que nos
preguntamos cuando no tiene solución
porque recordemos como les había
comentado hace unos momentos que podemos
tener tres casos que tenemos muchas
soluciones muchas soluciones a nuestra
ecuación todo esto que estoy haciendo es
es un repaso verdades ya muchísimos
vídeos que hemos hecho y entonces
podemos tener muchas soluciones podemos
tener una única solución una solución y
sólo una o bien podríamos pensar que no
hay solución verdad son las tres únicas
posibilidades que tenemos entonces si
nos damos cuenta bajo qué condiciones no
hay solución lo contrario nos da al
menos una solución qué es lo que estamos
buscando entonces cuando será cierto que
esto no tiene solución y eso es muy eso
sólo es cosa de recordar la verdad
tenemos nuestra matriz digamos que ya la
llevamos a su forma reducida y
escalonada no sé a lo mejor aquí tengo
un pivote qué sé yo
por eso aquí tenemos un pivote acá puedo
tener muchas cosas a lo mejor hasta aquí
tengo otro pivote en fin no tenemos está
esta forma ya reducida de la matriz
aumentada y cuando no teníamos solución
es cuando aquí teníamos un renglón con
puros ceros verdad puros ceros y aquí en
esta en esta en esta entrada teníamos
justo una entrada que no es cero verdad
es la única posibilidad para no tener
soluciones y todo esto ya es un repaso
verdad y de hecho si recordamos solo
para ir aclarando todas nuestras ideas
queremos ver bajo qué condiciones es
nuestra transformación en su proyectiva
y eso nos lleva a demostrar o ver
condiciones bajo las cuales el espacio
columna de la matriz coincide con todo
el codo minio verdad que pues es
esencialmente saber cuándo podemos
resolver esta ecuación y eso lo podemos
hacer si al llegar a nuestra forma
reducida y escalonada no ocurre esto que
tengamos todo un renglón con puros ceros
y esta y esta entrada no es cero cuando
esto ocurre no hay solución ok entonces
como es que vamos a proceder en general
y ves lo tenemos que poner como una
variable verdad entonces uno en la
práctica lo que hace es tomar este
nuestra matriz
tomamos esta matriz aumentada y con el
vector b que esencialmente es b1 b2 así
sucesivamente hasta b m
y esta es nuestra matriz aumentada y lo
llevamos a su forma reducida y
escalonada por renglones
bajar un poco más lo llevamos a su forma
reducida y escalonada y esta será lo
mejor algo así a lo mejor aquí tenemos
un pivote que se yo sale y aquí es cero
aquí tenemos a lo mejor otro pivote
y así si nos seguimos aquí y bueno como
nosotros tenemos variables no no tenemos
una ve arbitraria entonces lo escribimos
como b1 b2 bm y así entonces qué tal si
tenemos puros ceros en un renglón
tenemos aquí a lo mejor puros ceros
entonces del otro lado pues vamos a
tener algo que depende sólo de las veces
sí o sea a la hora de hacer todas las
operaciones correspondientes para para
reducirla y escalonar esta matriz pues
vamos a tener también operaciones con
los b2 b1 b2 hasta bm por ejemplo a lo
mejor nos queda no sé estoy escribiendo
un caso particular puede no quedar así
pero puede quedar como 2 b 1 + 3 b 2 - b
3 y así no tenemos en general una
expresión o una función déjenme decirlo
así tenemos una expresión f que depende
pues de v1 v2 y de todos estos veces no
hasta b
entonces si esta expresión debe ser 0
entonces va a haber algunos puntos por
ejemplo déjenme déjenme hacer un dibujo
aquí si tenemos
rm
rm a lo mejor habrá algunos puntos donde
si se cumple esta relación que 2 b 13
bueno esta función en general si nos da
0 para estos puntos verdad entonces esos
sí van a ser imagen al aplicar la
transformación t
y van a estar en la imagen de nuestro rm
ok al aplicarle t a algunos vectores en
rn entonces pero pero si si esto pasa
para estos para algunos no
necesariamente pasa verdad entonces la
única forma es que esto sea
completamente cero pero es una expresión
muy arbitraria entonces si no tiene
solución si vamos a escribirlo si no
tienes solución solución
a esta a este renglón de aquí para
algunos casos para algunos casos basta
con que haya al menos uno de hecho vamos
a tener varios pero bueno para algunos
casos de nuestro vector b entonces qué
es lo que concluimos entonces no
generamos no generamos
r m ok y por lo tanto nuestra
transformación no sería su proyectiva
verdad entonces solo para dejar un
poquito más claro esto no es propio solo
de este de este renglón de este renglón
verdad que vamos a tener una expresión
acá vamos a tener otra expresión de uno
más de dos menos tres b b b 3
en fin no eso ocurre en todos los
renglones pero en particular va a
ocurrir para este renglón en donde
tenemos puros ceros muy bien entonces
esto va a ocurrir solo para ir
redondeando te va a ser su proyectiva o
te es sobre t es sobre sí solos y louis
lo escribimos como si el espacio columna
es todo el condominio que es rm pero el
espacio columna es todo rm si y sólo si
verdad también lo podemos expresar de
esta forma la forma reducida y
escalonada por renglones de nuestra
matriz a tiene una entrada tiene una
entrada pivote tiene una entrada pivote
entrada pivote
en cada
cada renglón verdad eso es lo que
estamos diciendo es esencialmente aquí
necesitamos que en cada renglón haya una
entrada pivote para que no sean todos
ceros verdad entonces
si eso ocurre para cada renglón y
tenemos m renglones entonces debe haber
m entradas pivote m entradas pivot es
verdad eso es recordemos que aquí
tenemos m m m renglones y tenemos n
columnas verdad entonces
vamos a ir redondeando un poquito todo
esto
vamos a ir redondeando todo esto
recordando cuando pasa que tener como
como trabajamos con estas entradas pivot
todo esto es un repaso de lo que ya
hemos visto en otros vídeos y todo esto
te resulta lo mejor un poco extraño te
recomiendo que siga revisando los vídeos
anteriores entonces recordemos cómo
encontrar una base una base para nuestro
espacio columna de la matriz para el
espacio columna de nuestra matriz que
entonces tenemos nuestra matriz ahí voy
a hacer justo lo que habíamos hecho hace
ya muchísimos vídeos atrás y nos fijamos
en qué columnas tienen una entrada
pivote verdad entonces lo llevamos a su
forma reducida forma reducida y
escalonada por renglones que digamos que
es r
y realmente lo que tenemos que fijarnos
es cuántas columnas tienen entradas
pivote en esta forma reducida los
vectores correspondientes en la matriz a
esos van a ser una base para nuestro
espacio columna ok entonces necesitamos
y déjenme hacerlo por ejemplo un digamos
como en un ejemplo muy sencillito
digamos que tenemos la matriz a con sus
vectores a1 a2 y así sucesivamente hasta
a n ok y después de llegar a su forma
reducida y escalonada pues tendremos no
sé a lo mejor que aquí hay un pivote que
que hay un pivote a lo mejor aquí no
aquí tampoco que se yo pero a lo mejor
aquí sólo hasta el final tenemos un
pivote verdad entonces qué es lo que
ocurre me considero aquellos aquellas
columnas que tienen una entrada pivote
por ejemplo este y este entonces sus
vectores correspondientes en la matriz
original que en este caso sería a uno ya
n esos dos o bueno en este caso son dos
pero todos los correspondientes van a
ser una base de nuestro espacio columna
ok entonces
recordemos que el rango el rango de una
matriz es justamente la
dimensión del espacio columna ok y la
dimensión del espacio columna es el
número de vectores el número de vectores
de de cualquier base de cualquier base o
una base de nuestro espacio columna
entonces si repasamos muy bien este
enunciado y tenemos queremos tener m
entradas pivote quiere decir que si
tenemos m entradas pivote vamos a tener
m columnas que que sea que formen una
base es decir que queremos una que la
base del espacio columna sea justamente
r m verdad entonces necesitamos m
entradas columna perdón en m entradas
pivote lo cual implica ahora sí que
tengamos m columnas pivote m columnas
pivote por supuesto en su forma reducida
y escalonada o en otras palabras que el
rango de nuestra matriz
sea justamente m entonces ya para ir
redondeando todas estas observaciones
que tenemos podemos garantizar que t es
sobre o su proyectiva sobre sí sólo si y
podemos ir repasando qué fue lo que
hicimos queríamos ver bajo qué
condiciones éste era sobre dijimos que
esto es cierto si el espacio columna de
la matriz era todo el condominio rm para
lo cual utilizamos estas formas
reducidas y escalonadas veíamos que
cuando no hay solución de la ecuación a
x igual a b es justo cuando tenemos esto
verdad que que haya puros ceros y una
expresión de b1 b2 bm entonces no puede
pasar que haya puro ceros necesitamos
que en cada renglón que en cada renglón
hay al menos una entrada pivot de verdad
que de hecho haya una entrada pivote
entonces quiere decir que necesitamos m
porque son n renglón es verdad
teniendo esto se me concluimos que el
rango de la matriz debe ser justamente m
por lo tanto test sobre si sólo si el
rango de nuestra matriz a es justamente
m
ok entonces de esta forma decimos que si
tenemos nuestra transformación que va de
rn a rm
r m al menos este va a ser su proyectiva
es decir que no importa cualquier punto
que me tome yo en rm debe existir al
menos uno que bajo la transformación
llegue a dar a este punto pueden haber
varios verdad pueden haber dos eso se
vale pero al menos debe haber uno ok
entonces como siempre es más sencillo y
más agradable hacerlo con un ejemplo
vamos a tomarnos una función particular
por ejemplo una función que vaya de r2
r3 y digamos que esta función aplicada
al vector x sea esta matriz la 1 2 3 4 5
multiplicando a nuestros vectores
entonces nos preguntamos si está si esta
matriz es sobre y pues hay que irnos con
esto de las formas reducidas verdad
entonces tenemos esta matriz 1 2 3 4 5 6
ok y entonces empezamos a escalonar la
por ejemplo vamos a tomar este 1 si
multiplicamos este renglón por 3 por
menos 3 y se lo sumamos a esto esto se
queda como 12 esto por menos 3 es menos
tres más 13 02 por menos 3 es menos 6
esto sería -6 entonces aquí sería
si multiplicamos este por menos 3 sería
2 por menos 3 son menos 6 4 es menos 2 y
ahora si el primero el primero lo
multiplicamos por menos 5 y se lo
sumamos al tercero tenemos 1 x menos 5
es menos cinco más cinco son 0 2 x menos
5 son menos 10 más 6 son menos 4 ok y si
no seguimos por ejemplo aquí en el
segundo renglón podemos dividir entre -2
y tenemos 120 uno verdad y aquí lo
dejamos como 0 4
muy bien y entonces a que pasamos ahora
que por ejemplo si el segundo renglón lo
multiplicamos por menos 2 y se lo
sumamos al primero tenemos 0 x menos 12
0 1 es 11 x menos 2 es menos dos más dos
es cero y aquí tenemos 0 y 1 y ahora si
lo multiplicamos por menos 4 y se lo
sumamos a éste pues vamos a tener cero
cero entonces ahora si nos fijamos en
las entradas pivote que son justo este y
este y los vectores columna que tienen a
estos como pivote entonces justamente
tenemos aquí dos entradas pivote dos
entradas pivote y eso quiere decir por
supuesto que el rango el rango de
nuestra matriz está 1 2 3 4 5 6
de esta matriz es justamente 2 pero
nosotros necesitamos que sea igual a 3
verdad a 3 porque estamos ese es nuestro
nuestro nuestro dominio así que ese como
nos fue igual a la dimensión del
condominio entonces ese no es sobre ese
no es sobre y por lo tanto ese no puede
ser invertible verdad es una de las
condiciones para que una transformación
sea invertible entonces espero que esto
te sea útil ahora en el próximo vídeo lo
que vamos a vamos a enfocarnos es en la
segunda condición para que una
transformación sea invertible y eso es
ser uno a uno